and for my pick we're hearing from
superstar mariah carey for the first
time
in her three decade career she's talking
about how she overcame early struggles
before becoming the best-selling female
artist of all time
the singer-songwriter has a record 19
number one songs thank you very much
including
we belong together dream lover and
vision of love i love all of them
carrie has more hit singles than any
solo artist in history
in a new memoir that's called the
meaning of mariah carey
she discusses the difficult moments in
her childhood and relationships
ahead of its release she spoke to us she
says it was written for a little girl
who never felt seen or heard
it was just about for me emancipating my
inner
child the little girl that never really
felt seen or heard
and um you know that wasn't famous and
was didn't have money and
didn't come from means and you know
struggle with
race and identity and issues um
you know so you said mariah she was a
scared little girl why was she so scared
well there was a lot of
unrest in my house hold if there was a
household um
and you know i had uh difficulty with
having come from such a dysfunctional
family
i needed to kind of heal myself and heal
that inner
child of that i tried to keep alive
through all of the dysfunction and
mess listen you grew up biracial in a
white neighborhood no big deal now
but there certainly was a struggle for
you to fit in there was a series of
things that happened to you
that i thought was very traumatic so you
go to your friend's house
well so it was my friends that were well
friends
and they were having this sleepover and
you know so they invited me and and
mind you we had to drive to this place
which was like hours away
um to the hamptons and so i was
literally stuck there
when that incident took place but mariah
what happened
um you know so they pretty much
got me in the room cornered me and
started using
the n-word over and over and over did
you feel
mariah that you had to straddle both
worlds or being accepted in both worlds
i i didn't really feel accepted in any
one's
particular world this is like in one of
the songs that i
um it's one of my favorite songs that
i've done it's called
outside and i talk about feeling
ambiguous without a sense of belonging
to touch
somewhere halfway like these are things
that i've been talking about for a long
time so it's like people are like oh
you know she's talking in this book now
but i really i always felt like i was
expressing that
your family life was complicated um i
want to focus on your mother because i
thought it was interesting when you said
listen uh
jealousy comes with the territory when
you're famous
but when it comes from your mother it's
very painful
can you talk about that dynamic i didn't
know that your mom was a singer too
yes my mother um is a very talented
singer she went to juilliard she's an
opera singer
i've always credited her with exposing
me to music
um with uh really kind of saying don't
say
if i make it say when i make it so i
think you know there's
it's such a complicated relationship it
is complicated and i also thought that
it was very
difficult to me to read because there's
here you are
you're starting your career and your
mom's singing and she says
you should only hope that you could be
half the singer that i am
it definitely had an effect on me um i
don't even know that she would even
remember that
yeah that one statement did live with me
for the rest of my life though so
it's like you have to be so careful what
you say and
that's why it with my kids like i really
try to acknowledge
their talent and acknowledge when they
you know draw a picture for me or
sing or dance or anything that they do i
want them to
to know that it's also all about them
and their happiness
after reading your book it seems like
you want to be a different kind of
mother
am i correct about that yes you are
absolutely correct
i uh again for me it's very important
that
the kids always feel safe and that they
feel seen and heard and that they know
that
they are loved unconditionally you know
and that no matter what i'll be there
for them and that is very important to
me because
you know growing up and being alone in
the house um or alone in these dangerous
situations
was um was traumatizing you know tommy
mottola played a big part in your life
did you think you were in love in the
beginning because you said i intended to
be married to tommy for the rest of my
life
in the very beginning i did feel
protected by him i definitely felt that
we had
a bond in music for sure
um i've i felt that he believed in me um
and that was huge i didn't feel that um
support as a person though like i didn't
feel like he
got the fact that i was also you know a
human being with my own feelings and
thoughts
and needs you know even before the
actual
marriage the relationship was already
so skewed meaning
the power dynamics were never what they
should have been
in a real relationship it's ironic you
know my voice was being heard by
millions of people
you know on a label that he controlled
but my actual voice
as a woman as a human being was really
um kind of shushed
you know and not encouraged if i hadn't
emerged from that
i don't know what i would be do you
believe that there would be the mariah
carey who is a huge success that we know
you to be today
without tommy mottolo of course you'd be
mariah carey
but would you be at this level yes
well i always believed that this would
happen
did you so i did i always had that
feeling because i had to feel that i
could
surpass where i came from that i could
overcome
um my childhood and my dysfunctional
family and all the things that happened
to me as a kid
so you know we can all speculate what
would have happened or what could have
happened but
you know what did happen was a
partnership where we both worked
extremely hard
and we both benefited from that are you
still open to love again
because if there's one thing that's
clear about you you do love
love are you open to it i
do i'm definitely open to love
i just don't know about the marriage
part of it i mean like
how many times can someone get married i
don't know mariah it's like
i play around with the fact that you
know we've done this two times
of course you want all those things to
work out but
things happen what can i say i look at
this cover
number one i love the cover but what i
really like is a little girl picture on
the back
and so when you look back over your life
and all your life experiences the good
and the bad
what would you say to this little girl
oh
well first of all i would encourage her
and i would tell her
you know don't worry about everything
that's
that's going to come your way but brace
yourself
in a statement tommy mottola told us
quote i am deeply gratified for the role
i played in mariah's well-deserved
and remarkable success and continue to
wish her
and her family only the very best we
were unable to
contact to hear from mariah carey's
mother to get a comment from her
so yesterday i mean i i find her number
one
i'm i like her music like her music have
all her albums but i didn't really know
a lot about her personal story and i
tell you after i read the book
my heart really opened up to her this
came to my house yesterday
that's being sent out to people you want
to see on the box big emcee
you open it up yeah there's a copy of
the book wow
there's a copy of tissues and it says
you know i'm
i want you to be to read the book
writing the memoir was one of the
hardest things i've ever done but it was
humbling and healing at the same time
i wrote about my dramas my triumphs and
my struggles for survival
and i was i thought that was a very nice
touch to whoever she's sending it out to
but marilyn monroe was a role model for
her because she epitomized glamour
years later she ended up bidding and
getting marilyn monroe's piano
that sits in her home today well that's
really wow christmas that that
that that great song we all love all i
want for christmas is you she wrote it
because as a
kid the holidays didn't mean much to her
and so she wanted something that gave
her her own
sense of joy and last year as you
probably know it hit number one on
billboard for the first time
so she said she feels she lives in a
snow globe of joy and she was inducted
into the storm
i know that i like that
inducted into the songwriters hall of
fame this year which because she doesn't
get enough credit as a songwriter
exactly exactly she's been writing a
long time she says that that's very
soothing to her you know she's got a
there's eight octaves she can hit five
of them ridiculous got an
incredible voice so i'm cheering her on
yeah and glad that she's sharing so much
of herself how many can you hit you
octaves wise me me me me maybe maybe
that's it that's
two oh tony de cobo got jokes
he knows i'm a frustrated singer i just
know i'm bad at it but i love music so
much so
thank you mariah carey for spending time
with us the meaning of mariah carey who
can really sing is on sale tomorrow
and carrie's upcoming album it's called
the rarities will be available on friday